what kind of man at this point in your
life do you see yourself with
absolutely no one Kim Kardashian is
single and so not ready to mingle it is
what it is the reality star split from
Pete Davidson in August after nine
months together and on Monday Kim opened
up about her newly single status during
a stop by Live with Kelly and Ryan you
are single now yes stay off dating apps
okay it wasn't even an option good you
don't can't use your hands yeah
[Applause]
that is what you are and that's what you
need I did say before maybe I should try
to date a doctor or a scientist or
something so a bunch of attorneys and
scientists
yeah I'm just not I'm just not ready
back in February 2021 the schemas
founder filed for divorce from her ex
and father of her four children Kanye
West after six years of marriage can you
actually just go out on a casual date it
must be very difficult I don't think so
I think it would have to be something
like set up at a friend's house
something really chill nowhere out in
public yep I just I just want to chill
and last week yay spoke out in his first
major TV interview since his split from
Kim I'm just extremely happy can you
tell by my face
the rapper addressed the drama
surrounding the end of their marriage
including his very public social media
rants many of which were aimed at P
Davidson Kim's then boyfriend God sent
me from that crash just so I could beat
Pete Davis
this is the mother of my children
and I apologize for any stress that I
have caused even in my frustration
because God calls me to be stronger back
in April Kim was on cloud nine raving
over Pete during a chat with E.T what's
your favorite thing about him he's just
super genuine and it's just really fun
to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch TV and just do nothing following
their split A source told DT she is
definitely open to dating again and is
doing surprisingly well and staying busy
to keep her mind off the breakup I'm
just rolling with it earlier this month
Kim touched on her divorce from Kanye
and split from Pete during a chat with
James Corden I have to do something like
go to different places clearly it's not
working whatever I'm doing right so I
feel I don't know maybe like a hospital
and meet a doctor what a a law firm I
think it's going to be like scientists
neuroscientists biochemists doctor
attorney that's right maybe what I
Envision but for now Kim says she's
simply focusing on her life and kids I'm
not looking for anything I think I
really just need to be by myself and
focus and finish school so law school my
kids yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you